welcome to tucker carlson tonight what a
betrayal the war in afghanistan turned
out to be above all it was a betrayal of
the american public the people who for
20 years paid for the occupation it was
a betrayal of the ones who died there of
course and of the tens of thousands of
americans who will carry the scars from
this disaster for the rest of their
lives
they were lied to we were all lied to
and we have a right to feel bitter about
that
but the war in afghanistan was also if
we're going to be completely honest
about it a betrayal of the afghan people
our leaders made promises to them they
knew they couldn't keep honorable
countries don't do that it's shameful
imagine being an afghan employee at
bagram air base you woke up the other
morning to find your american patrons
gone they didn't tell you they were
leaving they just left
so what happens to you now in a country
run by the taliban
it's hard to think about that and yet
tonight many americans are thinking
about it and they're feeling distressed
as they do americans are kind people and
generous they are quicker and more eager
to help strangers than anyone else in
the world
we haven't seen polling on it but we bet
if you asked a hundred people should we
try to help afghans who are facing
persecution for helping us
most americans would say of course we
should
and we should be glad that they say that
you should be happy you live in a
country where your neighbors love
children and dogs and want to help
refugees
we are generous and empathetic people
and we should be proud
unfortunately there are many in our
ruling class who are anxious to take
advantage of that anxious take advantage
of our best qualities they see our
decency and our weakness and they
exploit those things and they do it
relentlessly let's try to save our loyal
afghan interpreters we tell them perfect
they think will open the borders and
change the demographic balance of this
country
of course that's exactly what they're
doing right now on our southern border
naturally in the name of human rights
and compassion and they would like to do
the very same thing with the disaster
unfolding in afghanistan the disaster
that they created
watch this kid from msnbc yesterday
remember as you watch that he is
regarded with total seriousness in
washington as a foreign policy expert
and that his fellow foreign policy
experts wholeheartedly agree with him
we're talking about uh an evacuation of
people who helped the wars and that's an
obligation of the united states but it's
sort of a moral floor that's functioning
as a moral ceiling the united states the
bush i'm sorry the biden administration
pardon me isn't doing things necessary
like increasing tps access letting in
refugees by the millions to escape their
certain fate at the hands of the taliban
so we must quote let in refugees by the
millions said the mustachioed foreign
policy expert the millions
millions is not a handful of loyal
afghan interpreters that's not even a
fleet of cargo planes full of loyal
afghan interpreters millions is a good
chunk of the entire population of
afghanistan brought to our country at
our expense to live in your neighborhood
at the very moment our national fabric
is fraying in case you haven't noticed
and the united states is becoming
unmistakably poorer
and that's not just one man's eccentric
opinion on msnbc you should know all the
clever people are saying exactly the
same thing the u.s should take as many
afghan refugees as it can demands a
recent headline in new york magazine
as many refugees as we can how many
refugees is that and is it really a good
idea to do that for us
don't ask you're not allowed to ask that
question because asking is racist
watch
the notion
that their sort of
horrific fear-mongering racism
doesn't carve out
the men and women in afghanistan
who kept our soldiers alive for two
decades is a new level of reprehensible
so right-wing personalities using the
crisis in afghanistan to push an
anti-refugee sentiment they're getting
caught up in what i call the brown
menace which is this uh trumper right
wing fear of people coming into the
country from central and south america
these people seem to be getting swept up
into that xenophobia it's stephen
miller's response to the collapse of
afghanistan the fall of kabul the
takeover of the taliban was look at
biden he's trying to he's trying to get
brown people to come into the country um
it's it's sickening and it's it's
pathetic
it's hilarious is what it is
the right wing hates brown people
the only problem is most most afghans
are not brown
your average green eyed posh dune is as
pale as anyone sitting on the set right
now essentially their bearded white guys
do the dummies on cable television know
that it's possible they don't know it
from their perspective anyone who
doesn't have access to the new york city
subway must be a foreigner and all
foreigners are brown we know that they
just are
so maybe they really not think that more
likely though they know the truth they
know that calling you a racist is the
fastest way to make you obey do we
really need millions of afghan refugees
in phoenix you ask shut up racist
okay
go ahead and do it
that's how the process typically works
in fact that's pretty much how it always
works with everything now
at this point fighting racism is the
universal justification for every bad
idea tear down our statues okay stop
teaching math okay get rid of
standardized testing all right defund
the police move millions of afghan
refugees to swing states to help the
democratic party
okay
oppose any of it and you're a racist
so in the end it always happens and in
this case it may happen it probably will
but what happens then to us
how will this new wave of immigration
affect america will america be a better
country or will it be a little more like
afghanistan which is to say not really a
better country
we can't be sure of what's going to
happen we can't see the future but for a
hint a glimpse
maybe we ought to pay some attention to
what has happened in europe recently
they've just gone through this
so one saturday night last month
authorities discovered the body of a 13
year old girl next to a tree in vienna
austria she had been drugged and raped
and murdered it took a few days but by
monday authorities announced they had
arrested two asylum seekers from
afghanistan for the rape and murder
shortly after that the chancellor of
austria identified the problem the
problem is austria's refugee policy
quote i find it intolerable for people
to come to us say they are seeking
protection and then commit cruel
barbaric crimes in austria
yeah but now they're getting used to it
because it's been happening with
increasing frequency throughout western
europe for years now six years and every
honest person knows that maybe the
dummies on cable news don't know it but
people who live there do cheryl bernard
knows that cheryl brown by the way has
been an advocate for refugees for
decades she's not against immigration
she's for it
but over time she's concluded that the
west simply is not capable not doing a
good job of successfully assimilating
many afghan refugees some
but many not at all
by every measure afghan resettlement in
europe has been an utter failure why is
that
maybe we should pay some attention
afghan refugees bernard wrote are
notorious for barbaric attacks attacks
that left-wing politicians in europe
frequently cover up for fear of being
called racist for example quote and this
is these are bernard's words a gang of
50 afghans who terrorized women in the
neighborhood of the linn's train station
were brushed off by a government
official with the remark that this was
an unfortunate consequence of bad
weather
end quote you could see that happening
here by the way
in another instance just last summer an
afghan migrant was arrested in germany
for raping an 11 year old girl
authorities released him from jail in
just a few days they said he was not
dangerous and anyone who disagreed with
that was a racist of course
the migrant then proceeded to rape
another girl this time she was 13 years
old
statistics show these are not just
anecdotes it happens a lot ask anyone
who lives there who is honest
germany's government just conducted a
study showing that rates of violent
crime in germany those rates have been
declining for years by the way shot up
abruptly in 2015 and that was the moment
when refugees from afghanistan and syria
arrived in germany
more than 90 of the new crimes in
germany the german government has found
were committed by asylum seekers more
than 90
this is not a slur it's not slander
those are the numbers and it's not just
a problem in europe ever been to
pakistan
here's one journalist acknowledging that
it is happening in places like iran and
yes pakistan as well
you know it's something like 2.8 million
refugees in the world are afghani
refugees basically about one in 10. and
let's remember during the trump years we
lowered the refugee admission to the
lowest possible level that it ever had
been and also many european countries
had shut their door to refugees and sent
them back to places like afghanistan and
that was before all of this happened so
i cannot even imagine what's going to
take place afterwards in countries you
know neighboring countries like pakistan
has something like 1.4 million afghani
refugees iran has about a million and
now you're seeing a huge influx that's
going to be going there as well too and
you're talking about destabilizing those
countries even further
okay
so afghan refugees have destabilized
countries into which they have moved in
large numbers but we have a moral
obligation to take them anyway really
why is that why is this our unique moral
burden
isn't the us government's first
obligation to its own people isn't that
the only point of having a government to
look out for its citizens why else have
a government
actually that might be a good question
for congressman peter meyer of grand
rapids he's a republican but he spent
months demanding the bide administration
import as many afghan refugees as
possible he just sent a letter to the
white house which was signed by dozens
of house republicans saying it's just as
important to evacuate american citizens
as it is to accept afghan refugees and
vice versa
he also tweeted that it's quote beyond
shameful in response to a report that
the administration is quote prioritizing
the evacuation of u.s personnel from the
country
so here you have a republican
attacking
the biden administration because they're
putting american citizens before foreign
nationals and lots of other republicans
on capitol hill agree and this might be
a moment to pause and state the obvious
none of this is the fault of the afghan
refugees they're desperate to leave
nobody blames them most of them are
probably great people the fault is ours
it's with people like that the idea that
you can move people from one completely
different country with a completely
different culture and language and
religion and history on the other side
of the globe into our country in large
numbers and everything will be just fine
is insane
it doesn't work there may be a good way
to do that nobody has yet figured it out
and until somebody does
maybe we should pause if we care about
our own people
the buy administration by the way is
still refusing to guarantee the safety
of americans going to the airport in
afghanistan joe biden's national
security adviser that would be jake
sullivan the road scholar came out
yesterday and suggested it is the fault
of the americans trapped in afghanistan
because they didn't leave sooner even
though mark millie and joe biden have
been saying for weeks that the taliban
would never take over in three days
couldn't happen so instead of rescuing
those americans still stuck there we are
saving afghans one cnn reporter called
natasha bertrand just reported that in
fact we're relocating more non-citizens
afghans than we are americans out of
afghanistan
about 330 u.s citizens left kabul
yesterday bertrand wrote along with
quote about 770 non-american family
members
so joe biden hasn't answered any
questions about this today he walked
away from reporters once again without
even addressing it meanwhile american
citizens remain trapped reporter phil
wegman from real clear politics says he
just got off the phone with senator bill
haggerty's office hagerty represents
tennessee
is getting reports of americans in safe
houses near the karzai airport who are
quote trying to figure out when they can
run for it
run for it that's what americans have
been left to do afghans are certainly
doing that take a look at this picture
of hundreds of afghans crammed into an
a7 a c-17 cargo plane
this was the air traffic controller's
reaction when he saw the flight lift off
okay how many people do you think your
jet
[Music]
800 people on your jet
[Music]
holy
holy cow
so every one of those 800 according to
congressman peter meyer who's like 33
years old quote risked their lives to
help protect american troops
really peter meyer how do you know that
well you don't know that you're just
making it up you don't know their names
you don't know their backgrounds you
don't know squat but he claims it anyway
stephen law who's one of mitch
mcconnell's chief political operatives
also wants you to know that every one of
those afghans on that plane is a hero
unlike you no need for vetting in fact
stephen law wants every one of them in
his neighborhood immediately we know
that because he just said so in social
media right
but not in his neighborhood actually so
it's pretty easy for people like steven
law to encourage unlimited migration of
refugees because in the end they're not
actually going to his neighborhood
they're going mostly to republican
states like texas where they'll be
settled in places where the democratic
party needs help
so big picture you've got to wonder how
long will republican voters tolerate
leaders who so clearly don't care at all
about them
as you may have noticed we have problems
here we have a housing crisis by the way
a big one do you have kids
ask them according to the wall street
journal the amount of available
entry-level housing in the united states
and that's defined as homes up to 1400
square feet is at a five-decade low
so when the supply shrinks
the cost rises the median value of a
home in california just rose above 800
000 first time in history less than 40
percent of the millennial generation
will own a home by the age of 34.
they're all renting and rent is going up
too a lot the growth in median rent
outpace the growth in median renter
income in nearly every state between
2001 and 2019 that's a disaster that's a
terrible development for human for
american citizens
so why is it happening well lots of
reasons but one reason it's happening is
america is becoming a lot more crowded
than it ever was and one of the reasons
for that is that we're now living
through the biggest influx of refugees
in american history
we are on pace for at least two million
illegal immigrants arriving in america
this year alone
that's far more than the number of
asylum applicants who arrived in europe
in 2015. that was over
1 million just over 1 million that
totally changed europe forever
so how many of the afghans that we
accept that stephen law and peter meyer
are demanding we accept are going to
bring family members with them
well the vast majority it turns out it's
not just the translators roughly 70 of
the special immigrant visas that we have
given out in recent years have gone to
relatives more than 70
so in general chain migration like this
has been a huge driver of our population
growth it's not americans having more
children it's chain migration
recent data show that each new immigrant
sponsored an average of 3.45 additional
immigrants getting a lot more than you
thought you were
between 2005 and 2016 9.3 million
foreign nationals were able to resettle
in our country for no other reason that
except they had extended family members
who already lived here
oh
so it's much more than they're telling
you how many of these afghans and their
family members
you have to wonder
are excited about coming to america
it's interesting maybe you should ask
that question
maybe you should ask ilhan omar
her position is the only reason that
american citizens might object to being
flooded with millions of new refugees
from afghanistan is because americans
people who are born here and built this
country are actually mediocre and
insecure
watch
and then you've got these crazy people
on the right um doing you know what they
what they always do uh with their
fear-mongering and their hateful
rhetoric and i know what some of these
people are uh worried about is that
they're worried that refugees like
myself when they come to this country
will outshine them
so the obvious response to that is
attack poor ilhan omar but we're not
going to do that the truth is this is
our fault she is our fault ilhan omar is
living proof that we are not very good
at resettling refugees she was saved
from a refugee camp in kenya as a child
by the kindness and generosity of
america and yet she has grown to hate
america and the people who live here
where did she learn those attitudes well
of course in college our colleges we
taught her to hate our country she
became worse after she got here
we ought to pause before we do that
again to anyone even if they've been
translators
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else